Steiermark mein Name ist
oberroße Hans neben mir steht der
Hirzberger Sebastian wir beide sind Teil
der rette und Berge Gruppe das Rettung
bergezuges hier bei der Kompanie in Graz
wir waren auch dabei in der Türkei
Anfang Februar für diese 10 Tage bei den
verheerenden Erdbeben heute zigtausende
Menschen das Leben verloren haben und
konnten auch einige Leben retten in
Verbindung mit dem Kontingent im
Einsatzraum
wie schaut es aus wenn man zu einem
Einsatz kommt das sollen wir euch heute
hier erklären
wenn die Rettung Berggruppe beim
einsatzforderungen europäische anstelle
angekommen ist also ein Gebäude was
zusammengestützt ist mehrere Stockwerke
mehrere vermisste Personen ist die gehen
wir nach einer sogenannten fünf
phasentechnik vor zu Beginn steht die
Phase 1 hier hat der Gruppenkommandant
den Auftrag ein Bild über die
Schadenstelle sich zu schaffen er auch
100 die Schadenstelle ob irgendwelche
Gefahren verletzte Person vermisste
Personen
in dieser Schadenstelle sind das
hauptsächlich durch Zeugen oder
persönlichen Einblick parallel dazu
läuft bereits schon die leichte Rettung
von sofortrettung von Personen die im
trümmerbereich außerhalb der
Schadenstelle liegen hinter Phase 2 ist
die durch Forschung und leichte Rettung
angesagt hier
Gruppen kommen letztendlich den Einblick
noch genauer Durchführen von der
schadenselement nebenbei kann der Retter
Druck leichte Rettungen mit
Gerät durchführen in der Phase 3 ist die
schwere Rettung hier wird hauptsächlich
oder Großteil Mauerdurchbrüche oder
Bewegen von schweren Lasten herangezogen
die nur eine gewisse Zeitbedarf in
Anspruch nehmen müssen Beispiel eine
Betonmauer durchbrechen und dahinter
befindet sich eine Person das war
eigentlich die Hauptaufgabe unten in der
Türkei in den ersten Stunden
des Einsatzes in der Phase 4 haben wir
den Auftrag die gezielte Beräumung hier
kommt auch schon schweres Gerät zum
Einsatz Hilfe zum Beispiel Bagger oder
Krähe wo man gezielt nach Hohlräumen
an der Schadenstelle sucht um etwaige
Überlebende zu finden in der Phase 4
können auch wie auch schon davor
Rettungshunde bzw
schallschutzgeräte oder sogenanntes
search Camps
eingesetzt werden
in der Phase 5 ist die restlose
Beräumung hier sprechen wir von diese
berühmten 100 Stunden die vergangen sind
und man fangt mit Gerät an schweren
Gerät an zu arbeiten Bagger und Krane um
etwaige vielleicht noch verschüttete
anzufinden aber hauptsächlich wird hier
noch mehr totenberger und durchgeführt
sicher erkläre ich den Rettenberg ist
das Nummer zwei der besteht da mal aus
einem Druckluftkompressor mit einem
integrierten Tank und einem Motor heraus
Druckluft erzeugt damit wir noch
verschiedene Gerät wie du ansichtlich
benutzen können aber da vorne
ersichtlich den Abbau Hammer mit
verschiedenen Bohrstangen Bohrstangen
Längen und in verschiedenen Tiefen
Löcher zu bohren und vielleicht einen
Kontakt mit der vermissen Personen
herstellen wir haben dazu verschiedene
Bohrkronen im Einsatz wir haben da einen
ab bauhammer mit verschiedenen meiseln
Gerät spitzmeißel
flachweißel und da den grabsparten da
gilt die Devise ihr spitzer des Werkzeug
desto härter ist der Untergrund
ein weiteres Gerät das man in der Türkei
Einsatz hatten ist das sogenannte
schalungsgerät
dieses Gerät
dient dazu dass wir bei eingestützten
Gebäuden oder trümmerkegeln
klopfen leichtes Kratzen von
verschütterten Personen feststellen oder
wahrnehmen können die sich durch die
Stimme nicht mehr bemerkbar machen
können aufgrund Staubentwicklung oder
aufgrund der lange aufgrund der
Verletzungen die sie vor Ort haben ein
weiteres Gerät des Rettung der Rettung
bei Gruppe ist der hebekissensatz klein
der ist fürs spreizen heben und Drücken
von schweren Gegenständen bis zu einer
Kraft von 41,7 Tonnen möglich
wie wird das Ganze angetrieben wir haben
hier ganz normale
Druckluftflaschen mit Atemluft quasi
Atemschutzflaschen oder Feuerwehrleuten
mit denen wir über das Steuerorgan die
beiden Hebekissen hier bedienen können
der Vorteil bei diesem Gerät
und somit leicht bei Betonplatten oder
ähnliches zwischendrin
Gruppe ist der Rettung Nummer 4
grundsätzlich ein motorbetriebener
Hydraulikaggregat mit zwei Schläuchen
bis zu 20 Meter ausziehbar
einem Spreizer im Arbeitsbereich mit
einer spreizkraft von ca 7 Tonnen eine
Schere zum durchzwicken von dorstahl
oder Armierungen von Beton circa 20 mm
Durchmesser des Drahtes oder Stahls
und eins letzte Gerät ist ein
doppelwirkender Hydraulikstempel mit
einer Schubkraft von ca 6 Tonnen und
einer Zugkraft von ca 3,5 Tonnen